guess I did a little Facebook questions
asking people whether they want to see
you for the next real thoughts and I
think the one I got the most likes
seeing how I didn't see it so I gotta be
a surprise so seeing how surely the
biggest blockbuster is the most exciting
film to come out this year
alien confidence is coming out uh why
don't we talk about Alien Resurrection
and in no other way ties into a review
we're doing right now I believe this is
the one that swore a Sigourney Weaver
off of doing any more of these so
there's that I mean thanks for that you
scared your marquee star away because of
this film this was like the one time
where it's like okay can very cuz
there's two times no I'll even say three
times were felt like she would come back
and you know it was um this one and then
what's alien versus Predator say okay
let's weigh in G and then was Prometheus
because all of those were promising us a
fair fight get why they kinda gave the
same bullshit I would say that I get
like she picked it because I asked it
you have to pick it and I'm just like
there was enough things where it's just
like oh you could do you could have some
fun with this you can start manipulating
the character as she good as she bent
like they were peaches in there them
like I could see how you could get
fooled by this script and be like who
maybe I can have fun with this and we
can take the franchise in a different
direction and originality afterwards
will prevail
that never happened um but I I could see
why and I feel like maybe I feel like
this film would have played better now
that would have been rough because
aliens was so open unto them like maybe
this would have played better if it had
replaced alien 3 like you if you pretend
alien 3 didn't happen then jump to this
but you would have been dry what
happened to rim I'd be pretty pissed off
at this followed healthy no I guess I
mean I did not like Gilead 3 by would be
really pissed off at this possibly guess
this is almost a comedy it's like I
don't know
in what universe this could have worked
none is like a B film and you know you
kind of got and it has a lot of people I
like I like the director I like you know
delicatessen sitting watching I guess
okay I like Ron Perlman I guess I like I
guess thought of saying is maybe I would
have put up with thee let's resurrect
Ripley and do this thing if I didn't
have to already sit there alien three
like the very idea of alien resurrection
to me bothered me mate I guess what I'm
saying is the idea of doing this movie
maybe would have bothered me less if I
didn't have to sit through alien 3 but
once you ended it with alien 3 I'm just
like okay we're done we may not have
liked it you know and but weren't done
when I was young man for one thing about
alien 3 I respect is it was like fuck it
it's over when I was younger that's what
actually drew me to it cuz I'm like okay
good it doesn't stop with alien 3
because at the time that was the word
alien film now there's like several to
choose from but uh but I like the idea
of like okay like maybe we can keep this
going again and I could search help from
the trailer wasn't it okay if I was like
nah maybe I'll be fun anyone is really
so stupid honestly is I would have just
much preferred if they had just been
like fuck it let's just remake alien 3
and make it a better move yeah I'm down
for Islands always happen you know I
would have but to do a Alien
Resurrection be like well now we're
going to bring Ripley back and I mean
it's so amounted that nothing cuz no
absolutely not because it's like it was
basically like this was the amazing
spider-man 2 or the amazing spider-man
reboot like we thought it was going to
be something on then maybe we could
start over and I was like nope that
amount of I'm not doing the same shit
absolutely well nothing uh and doing it
so real like so really bad that's what's
so interesting about this because like
the directors done a good stuff and
interesting stuff and everything and but
this is where it's kinda like getting
ready to see a director who just was
complete it's like a tent bird for
Allison walk away you how to be dumbek
but it I guess no that was actually the
exact wrong yeah it's it's you I'm not
sure I would have thought it would be
perfect I think he was out of his
element
I don't think like I think this style of
movie was not tailor-made for him
like Tim Burton's Alice in Wonderland is
a different beast altogether like
because I feel like Tim Burton could
have done it maybe it was a certain idea
yeah but this one I just like I just
don't feel like he was made for this
universe you know and I'm not saying
like Prometheus or any of those but you
can tell James Cameron and Ridley Scott
and even fucking David Fincher were
somehow kind of made for this you look
at David Finnigan films like okay even
if the film sucks he was made for this
universe visually speaking like this
worked like yeah the visuals an Alien
Resurrection I feel like it I can't
remember if it was like I thought it was
too colorful or too but you know it was
just yellow and brown I was kind of it
we got an alien three but it was done
it'll get people better anyway dinner it
didn't look scary I didn't get recently
rosemary and quartered al berries yeah
claustrophobic it was uncomfortable here
it was just a locally itself cartoony
and of the kind of humanized alien at
the end with the goofy skeleton 3 what
work something out of a bad Castlevania
game or bad scooby-doo episode like what
view this alien ones all along Rick I
say this because we haven't seen a
requiem yet out of all the alien movies
this one I will say it's probably the
most creatively bad because I do think
it's just a batshit insane
oh it's laughs I love it it is like
Brendon Europe and no I'm on parole man
and films interesting okay well this is
the mortal kombat argument where people
like how could you show us Vodacom
annihilation more because it's so
batshit bad that it's more memorable and
this is where those rare kids honestly
if you put a gun to my head you can only
watch one of these two films alien 3 or
Alien Resurrection
over our area I wouldn't even blink I'd
be like alien resurrection because I'm
like it is so laugh-out-loud bad that's
a little that at least I'd be like all
right give me the entertainment of
watching real shit I'll get ready 3 is a
better movie both got it I'd like 83
puts me to sleep every time it was like
yeah all right
I might take alien 3 because I'm a
little bit more fascinated how because
it's an ague
Phil it is you know yeah yeah you may
have a point there because it is Bai of
alien movies yeah get something good at
it alien for you just know it's like
know it with the exception of Ripley you
know start having the DNA of the alien
and then the weird alien hybrids of her
in the testing room whatever lighten
that element was interesting but if you
look it doesn't belong in this universe
that belongs the difference would be
ordering to offer he early parts of this
film it's the only time where I feel
like okay maybe maybe we can get
something out of this and I just falls
apart and it does nothing is a killer
you and again I mean it was kind of cool
seem to get sucked through the little
hole at one um but again I'm just like
and we're right back where we said like
that's the same fucking story and it
never goes and that's why really only
the first two are really worth watching
yeah because by by the time the second
ones over the novelty's worn off there's
nothing you can do now and like if what
I'm reading about the reviews are ready
for a alien covenant rise oh I know what
it's over I'm not the I'll just say
right here I'm not seeing it unless it
gets like yes a little worse or the
absolute I'm over me using from overseas
or coming in and it's just what I
thought is like yeah here's the exact
same fucking movie again don't care I
don't care right why are we still making
me well that's what they they were stood
they were literally like literally
Ridley Scott is like you know in his
wait 70s now it's you know I hope he
lives a long life but they're like
gluten it's just natural you're not
going to have X amount of years left
like can he be spending his time doing
something do like it like we're still on
this like really the is the one that you
know and it's funny because when you
really think about in terms of the Alien
movies you're right there's honestly in
terms of genuine actual good films like
hate meld a good movie there's only two
alien and aliens uh there are no others
like you can argue like alien 3 has
moments yeah but I mean they're there
but when you talk about the great alien
movies is that all of them honestly
again I just be Requiem but all of them
I will admit have had something kind of
interesting
oh this moment
there are moments I work you to my
laundry no no no you're gonna call alien
versus Predator great no no no I can't
no is the awesomest cuz it says and
there were some awesome scenes in a
movie I need to sister I didn't see
through it and our boredom together any
of that shit yeah so and it's been the
same like so you know and the thing too
you know because this does go over the
top and everything and the one thing
else kind of like it's a little fun to
watch for how over the top it is but at
the same time I can't not the same thing
like so Harrison Ford kind of come back
to acting it looked a lot like Sigourney
Weaver was trying to over cop and say
something she's been away for a while so
she just comes in just I'm tough
mm yeah who do I ask fuck to get off of
this ship and it just so doesn't feel
natural in the first two films it even
alien 3 she was so naturally badass and
this way she's just uh uh no searching
back yeah just like yeah but here's the
problem who knows because it's not
really Ripley it's a clone we're talking
about the different character she may
have been trying to play it different
who knows what the direction was under
that light I think that's best the thing
it all comes down to the directing the
director has to try to guide you I said
I don't think this director was made for
Disease I'm not sure the director knew
what he was doing well and here's what
that you know guy let's face it I love
his movies but he makes live-action
cartoon everything it's not a live actor
her to and everyone talks like that and
looks like that yeah that's probably
what doing with the Dan Hadiya that gets
like face-planted in the back Bunyan and
then looks at his brain
here's the thing it's an awesome scene
belongs in another movie not because it
isn't the idea isn't scary if done right
I'm like us a terrifying scene he looks
so goofy look her even the shot before
yeah so ridiculous throwing the grenade
and following it in and go solo cartoon
so ridiculous that is it I laughed like
I laughed at that scene it wasn't scary
at all and I'm like and it could be like
if you did that seem really seriously
like
or movie it could be great it's like
you're looking at a piece of your own
brain like that's crazy like it but know
is that that scene was goofy those as I
said the the skeleton the the half-human
alien at the end which was a cool idea
I'm like well I actually also that look
goofy the way it dies is both awesome
but also Google I don't have a human
cartoon do you think around Perlman
alright and I am these are all human
cartoon all guys that I love these guys
a lot of yeah it just is not spinning in
this universe and maybe any of those
three could have fit under a different
director but the way he directs them
like a cartoon it doesn't work like you
know again that's like a dream team I'm
like how could this movie not be great
with those three and it ends Sigourney
Weaver and and then Winona Ryder now
who's made a huge comeback that movie I
did that movie I think was the death
nail in her coffin yeah no not that I
like when it started suddenly it was
like when Orion was like help yet row
today was just like yeah maybe not she's
stealing shit oh by the way this will be
directed back we read this will be took
out two people Sigourney who just said
after this room fuck it all and uh and
Winona Ryder who I think people just
looked in like and I have a problem with
motor rider I think she can be amazing
so miscast in this greatly freaking
miscast I don't buy her as that Android
for a second I think how would you even
do I'm sure there's a way an interesting
well that's the one thing I'm shocked
they didn't get because this director is
that seems like something that director
could do this robot sort of faking
emotions you know stuff like that but so
has the wide-eyed what's going on but
you feel like he could do that and
that's like but it one of the biggest
misstep is that she was so bland and not
interpret belongings in the different
film if this were like a fucking Big O
movie and Shira Dorothy I'd be fine no
no even though it was our Dorothy know
there was her name way even she in her
blank stare and it was so much more
interesting than anything writer was
in this movie it's just like there was
it did not know what it wanted to do
with that idea and that character anyway
of making her into the very wolf boy
like you know you believe in then she
says a program to believe in it how
fascinating what that do you think that
don't pin to that hood it's great if
they went oh Red Dwarf and talk about
silicon and prison not written that the
iron shell lay down with the lamb where
do all the calculators go but it
nothing's really human heaven of course
not just say that up stop you all humans
from going nothing no I said like a part
of uses like well that would be an
interesting commentary so is religion
just programmed into it like that no
they go nowhere with it no we're um
without the interesting angle in the
whole you know sugar comes back and no
correction I mean it thing is my problem
is why I feel bad for Sigourney Weaver I
could see you're looking at the script
and looking at some of these ideas and
going that's interesting this and to em
in the movie I did the same thing I'm
like that's interesting that's and damn
that's now unlike Sigourney Weaver we
didn't know where this was going
I know when her excuses she had to go
from the beginning of the script to the
end and let's maybe never rewrite
somehow is a vintage are maybe that
changed after the treatment she read
before she signed on I don't know but
but yeah I mean we didn't know where it
was going so I'm just like oh this is
all interesting in somewhere about the
midway point I just got this sinking
feeling I'm like yeah yeah like we're
we're not coming back from there because
that's what was worrying me is just like
even when it was still interesting kind
of in the first seven like okay where
are you going with this I I realized I
wasn't scared well and that was the
biggest thing I was like alien three I
may not have liked my I'm like it still
scared me it's not mean there was a huge
time difference because I was much I was
in suspenseful I'll give it I don't
think everybody well over the
entertainment when alien three came out
but so now I'm like in high school or
something or what did when did Alien
Resurrection come on uh I was either in
high anyhow annex okay that was good
yeah high school like so a part of me
felt maybe was like well I'm just jaded
now like I don't get
yeah but the more that I know I still
get scared it's just isn't fucking scary
no a lot of we today obviously are still
pretty damn so we could have been
derided as stupid as it was probably a
couple teens I fell for jump scares more
scarier in an Alien Resurrection so you
know there's two scenes in this movie
that I think I'm like okay I could see
that an alien film what is when she goes
in the room and sees all the other
versions of her because again that's
showing the evil the corporation that
always is like a theme in these movies
that I can see the director another one
has been we're trying though though i
can imagine see that i both it's both
the most realistic thing about it and
also i'm just sick of it no i agree i'm
like i'm finding of it something i guess
be nailing film the other one was in a
true-to-life but I'm just I'm just going
I'm like okay at some point can we get
past
oh the corporation's trying to fuck us
all well you're sympathetic I couldn't
be but I'm just a Cocina Din this series
but the other is when Brad Dourif is
testing the alien and you know getting
close as they're showing the teeth and
then it shows his teeth and he won how I
can't fucking I went over and you know
it stops he's like huh or a fast learner
like this very kind of fucking eye yeah
that was the if you want a few moments
where I was most invest in the movie it
was when Brad Dourif was testing them
out and when the aliens figured out how
to fucking break out of there yeah that
taught me more without really much
different wasn't really a dialogue Brad
door makes a couple of observations but
we couldn't just notice no I think all I
didn't know where a theater yeah no
dialogue and we learned so much about
the Xenomorphs right there and that was
the best part of the movie and then once
they break out it just all goes downhill
I'm like this is always but that part I
thought was fasting the way they kill
one to break out like it was very
Jurassic Park like they then yeah the
way they look at you and they look at
the smaller one I mean it's like yeah
there is something really fascinating
about
and that one looks at you you can tell
she's figuring things act um yeah
trying to think try thing if there's
anything else I have no interest in the
new alien movie I really really really
do not want to see I'm going to try not
to see it if the head baby says because
they have to either get amazing reviews
or the worst reviews like it's so bad
it's good like you just have to see how
bad it is and for me because I didn't
like but it's like it's really not the
worst of the words or anything like that
cause at least I look pretty
I'm sure this won't look pretty too but
it's I'm sure thank you just go through
them all so laborious - I just saw the
trailer for them and whoa looks pretty
like I mean he's he always has
interesting cinematography well he's
producing that one he's not directing
though oh he didn't do it Oh shows you
how much I keep up on news no I thought
he was - and I thought man that actually
don't wait every night Benson did ya
welcome
so it is a movie with the stuff yeah no
you know what with how he's been
directing I am totally okay with I'm not
directing to make like I don't think
I've seen a good movie from him since I
was a like match men or matchstick men
something like that I was good today I'm
a stick man yeah like fun okay um cooler
than like I seen of yourself I just feel
like it's been so all over the map since
fucking gladiator yeah I would not agree
with you and say hell maybe they're I
think um they're like the beginning of
okay we're just gonna winnable pretty
see - a cannibal is not in the Hannibal
is not what happens and really guys
family is so pretty bad I love it worse
material with such garbage but I I loved
how insane that much like much like the
book the first half is pretty good and
then just like the book once they get
out of Florence takes a nosedive like
the movie doesn't so I can't entirely
lame Ridley Scott for that but I'm just
like yeah that wasn't great if I have a
bell on the list for reviews to do I
mean I wanna do I don't talking about
that it's helped he didn't say he it
just doesn't like nothing to do with
things I'll successful life now like a
comic book movie that movies so good and
honestly I'm just looking at a great
dragons the stronger story yeah I like
the movie red dragon almost by default
just cuz the source material was better
and I'm like I'm not convinced it's
actually directed that much better I
just think that the source material was
so much better than it was like yeah I
kind of like Brett Ratner's red dragon
my god I love our dragon I love
Manhunter and man oh yeah man there is
different as you yes nice red dragon and
Manhunter together the things I like
more out of each into one fill I have
told I do it there's like an Oscar movie
between the two of those I'm not a huge
because Brian Cox's non-performance and
Manhunter doesn't bother me but I'm just
like yeah he exists because this was pre
hit but so if I could splice some
advances but Anthony Hopkins performance
the red dragon wasn't great either I
know I could just like mold those and we
did the one because they're parts of
Manhunter I love so much better than the
red dragon but red dragon also nails a
couple of things that are like dammit ya
know they're both that is one of the
most fascinating compare and contrast
movies because they both in so many
respects nail what the book was doing
and then in other respect it's like okay
creative liberties or whatever but man
is it interesting to compare those two
just like Alien Resurrection and aliens
are so interesting to compare and
control one is really good and the other
is not know pretty bad uh but yeah I
will say there was like uh some people
are just like well how how could you
look at this and even things like even
look at the trailers how could you think
is good be any good because it really
was like you know this was Heartland
home this was the other charms are
positive most are so balanced for the
franchise not destroy it ya know I think
we wanted we wanted to believe we are
foolishly optimistic we were and we were
hoping I was the ether that wasn't scary
I was hoping it would be cool and fun
and you know maybe we listened more
towards the aliens with the action and
stuff there's just like new very bad
every time so
I can't think of them how I don't know
much else so okay like is it I so we
have not seen requiem reporter so out
there alias I just as bad as I don't
know I'll be good but I'm we have we're
ready to talk about this play to make
fun of but yeah I I'll just say I saw
spot to that book I don't know yes good
I don't know how you I'm sorry I don't
have a soft spot for it but I guess it
was so top down and shat upon that my
expectations were so low them like not
good but honestly it's got more standout
moments to me than some of the other one
oh yeah I'm like I'm like at least I
knew going in how dumb this was going to
be meant maybe it helped a bit
what left a resurrection and then after
the to the alien vs. predator movies
were there any alien lord I think it
just went to Prometheus and I was kind
of dumb I don't what what can you do
with this story well has it been
Prometheus I think everyone's done it's
not going to be scary it's gonna go into
the mythos and the backstory it's going
to try something really different is
like nope it's just doing the exact same
shit except it's not new anymore what
I'm hearing is incorrect we get to see
it all over again I leave their pets
with couples why it was some of my
favorite by fair review is for BBC news
is like I have never heard the words my
wife mentioned so many times in a film
like they never let you forget
apparently everybody's American except
more time from the fugitive my wife yeah
oh yeah and you know I saw one clip from
this new one what would you do Dave
Israel it was like what to add some ever
just man cuz I didn't see the earth
actually taken over by aliens that's not
that what any kinda like Terminator III
no idea like how do you like that's the
problem
aliens was so definitely like you an
alien yet the one xenomorph the crew
gets slowly killed off and only ones
left
you have aliens now you have the colony
with multiple aliens you have an alien
queen us fuckin Space Marines most of
them killed off Hansel and we got three
left I think
um so I or kind of a cause vicious cut
in half and so I want them weird with me
as prior you go no I won't from easiest
frogs which is a back story about where
they come from almost like a missile is
almost like just watching this alien
race maybe there's people in it it's not
really a big deal it's more where they
came from this other innovation to do it
like alien vs. predator only smarter
like where they're going through ruins
and move it up no I won't have as much
people I would have maybe a person or
two but it's mainly following this alien
race against my figure here's my big
question because I mean that's the
problem of aliens is it so was perfect
that it seems impossible to top like
they elevated it to level of life we've
got so many aliens the Queen and listen
that unless you top that which i think
is the problem the series I don't get
maybe do not go different oh now here's
the question do you think that wrecks
something though for answering all the
questions
well purple for media soon but second uh
it's kinda like what Batman like I
didn't want to know what happened to
Batman after his parents were shot but
because when Bandai begins came out but
okay no look we have to really read you
this read to find us and they show you a
great detail what happened even though
it's not what I want to see I thought
was interesting it locked me in it gave
a new point of view and I got in a torn
because on the one hand I'm like well
that would be different then maybe would
be interesting to know like how does
uniform the how the Xenomorphs work of
the background the mythos and all that
but another part of me is like maybe
it's just better if it's unanswered I
think it's just gonna ruin it for me I
agree but the task on me because I think
there should be any more alien movie so
if you put the tascam you say create
life in this again do something with
this I probably wouldn't go scary I go
horror but one goes scary I would go
some sort of fantasy horror going into
the backstory of where these creatures
came from how they were created all this
stuff instead just focusing on these
people looking around again say Oh
wonder where that came from you see one
new creature and then that's it and
that's like well now we have five more
we know your charisma yeah like always
my mind how that original crew is the
original crew is really weird because I
probably don't have a lot of charisma
but they're uncomfortable with me but
they're yeah like it's almost like they
just all kinda are just tolerating each
other but that somehow makes it
interesting to watch the speak any
others I felt like and this was the
secret to the Cameron film the Cameron
film is different that they're all
fucking to ooze and charisma like even
the annoying guys like Bill Paxton is
character like you kind of love watching
him at his freakout carry him over like
you're you kind of lured just like yeah
I like these guys I want to see most of
them make it through yet the commander
was a bit of a friggin and of course
Paul Reiser who everybody just once dead
because he's Paul Reiser but I tighten
up against um but ever since that I feel
like there's been no cast where I'm just
like yeah I really want to follow these
people I just don't I kind of want to
follow Ron Perlman that's just because
yeah okay okay I'll give you mom Perlman
oh no and I will give you again the lead
in alien versus president I like
following her okay that's the one person
though I know in terms of a cab anybody
else but on the other Space Marines get
killed and aliens I so bad yeah is like
shit down or it's like you're the
commander who didn't quite know what he
was doing when everything falls apart
like get the hell out of here and he
like fucking freezes and I feel bad for
I feel bad yeah it's not a situation
like during a so it's just like oh my
god I feel bad like he just wasn't
prepared I and what a stress will see
your heart throughout if you wanted to
be a little I know from BP to just be
yeah it last yeah if you want to do
something but the same time you're like
I filled you guys see always I've been
doing something he only at first and you
hate big you're like the only person
really hate his polarizer um and I
didn't even hate him at first is when
they do the reveal and there's like okay
he's do Schmidt legs but yeah something
I just know I've never gotten at and
they keep doing the same fucking movie
but can never get that one thing right
and it killed alien vs. predator for me
because maybe that for his forty minutes
would have been tolerable and I liked
any of those people just
and that is the one thing you're right
about Alien Resurrection I'll give it
that one bonus point is the plot is
stupid everything I do like Ron Perlman
I do like some of those characters they
just didn't do anything with them they
had natural charisma unlike everybody
else
yeah Perlman and then via the do four
three musketeers one IVIG
gets a cool voice like that it's like
but the camera him really early I'm like
I love it
he was good that turned him also early
in movies all the guys the guy in the
wheelchair I thought he was cool
I got him in his his boy scout on my
nerves no I'm taking it's just ice no
can I see Madonna listen no I don't see
him another fella he's great you know
you did all that guys movie i am i just
couldn't stand with ya I don't know I I
just feel like it's time to retire
yeah the series please oh because I'm
not sure I'm not convinced that I would
like it actually knowing the whole
Baxter like that was my problem goes
from the shell and I haven't seen the
movie yet I'm going to try to catch as a
dollar cinema but that was my problem
with what the series did in one of the
later anime series they start fleshing
out the majors backstory and I'm like I
something realized but I don't want to
know this I don't give a shit I like the
fact that she's a character that just
does her fucking job and like that is
who she is that you don't need to know
what exactly her whole tragic back
sorrow is is the number one thing that's
already bothering me from everything
I've seen about the movie is that like
our backstory I'm like what do you do if
you don't do this yogurt at all somebody
like I'm sorry yeah well somebody was
like well they're taking pieces from the
later anime series with us but I hate it
that's not going to sell me on the movie
you're sorry like but yes I don't tell
anyone else from what I know I I do like
I do kind of want to see it like I'm
okay watch your cinemas but not now
we're not right there yeah but bottom
line just stop with the aliens I look
who Dom it maybe this new one will like
change everything you know I really want
maybe lucky maybe we'll eat our words
but somehow I almost hope that's the
case but it's like I really don't think
kind of like Wonder Woman
although I have more host know I'm
grilling yeah like know what at least
looks good yeah it doesn't look like the
same shit alien companies just looks
like this thing but it's like even if we
eat our words with Wonder Woman it's
just like I like is my tank I'll be good
yeah I think that one will be good
this one is yeah I mean we'll see but
that that's my early prediction so yeah
that's about it guys and until then um
my own secret recipe highly toxic
contagious oh you read a life on the
movie who gets shit game over man game
over
thank you it's a better I don't write
you